eggs are quick cheap and easy and if you
don't have them in your fridge already
you probably should here are five easy
ways to cook eggs perfectly every time
you don't need much for these first two
preparations all you need is a good
non-stick skillet doesn't have any
scratches on it a rubber spatula some
salt and pepper and a good amount of
butter you want to use a non-stick
skillet eggs are notoriously sticky
because of all the protein and a lot of
other stuff in there and you also want
to make sure that you're not using any
metal utensils on the pan itself first
up scrambled eggs one of my personal
favs scrambled eggs there's a lot of
different ways to cook them this is lid
that we prefer at tasty kitchen it's a
great idea to crack them into a separate
bowl first one in case you have any big
chunks of eggshell in there funny shell
does get into the bowl itself totally
fine take an egg shell that you just
cracked and use that to go in and get
the shell out while it might seem easier
to crack them into the pan and scramble
them in there it's not really a good
even way to do it you'll have some big
chunks of egg white some big chunks of
egg yolk just trust me it's an easy bowl
to clean just throw them in a bowl first
and scramble them in there so instead of
adding milk or cream we just use a lot
of butter you start with about two
tablespoons of butter get it nice and
foamy in the pan and when it's pretty
much all the way melted we're going to
season our eggs with a bit of salt and
pepper and any other seasonings you want
and then into the pan we want to keep
our heat pretty low here and we're
actually not going to move the eggs at
all until we kind of see a little bit of
the egg setting on the sides of the pan
when you start to see a little bit of
the eggs set that's when you want to
take a rubber spatula and from the
outside in push the eggs towards the
center and kind of all around the pan so
that all the eggs are cooking pretty
evenly when they're about three quarters
of the way cooked we're going to do a
real sneaky trick here and add a few
cubes of butter
that's another tablespoon cut into fours
or so we're going to melt those cubes of
butter into the eggs themselves and
they're going to kind of emulsify
sort of this like creamy nice meltyness
into the scrambled eggs and they add
this like really beautiful creamy
texture at the end
so we recommend taking them off a little
bit before you think the residual heat
within the eggs will continue to cook
them until they're the perfect doneness
i mean it definitely takes an art and
takes a little bit of time to get the
scrambled egg right but there's just
something so good about it just kind of
like hits all those salty creamy fatty
notes for me and i just really really
love having scrambled eggs
the fried egg i think people are afraid
of fried eggs i don't know there's like
so many different ways to do it it's
like should pan be high heat should be
low how do you get that perfect color
we're gonna do ours on a medium heat for
the fried egg so add butter to the pan
add your egg into the butter so you want
it to be hot enough that the egg white
is kind of setting when it goes in let
it start cooking and you want to make
sure that it's not so hot that the egg
white itself is like going all over and
boiling like crazy add just a few drops
of water at this point and immediately
cover with the lid and that's going to
create a good amount of steam in the pan
so it's going to help cook the egg white
without being on such a high heat that
the egg yolk will cook through as well
at that point you know once it's cooked
for a few minutes you have the world's
most picture perfect egg
really yellow vibrant yolk the white is
cooked through there's none of that
weird like snotty bit that no one likes
like undercooked egg white
it just takes maybe a minute or two with
that steam on top and then you have a
picture perfect egg i mean you could
instagram that
it's a million things on the internet
like how to get the perfectly hard
boiled egg we've tested a whole bunch
and this is our tried and true method to
get your perfect boiled egg every time
you want to put them over medium-high
heat because you want to bring them to a
boil but you want it to kind of happen
slowly so similar to potatoes we're
doing this because we want them to cook
really evenly we don't want the outside
to cook for the inside cans once it's at
a rolling boil you want to take it off
the heat cover and set your timer
between 4 and 16 minutes depending on
how you like your yolks cooked and then
once they're cooked to your liking you
want to immediately take the eggs out
and put them into a nice bath
that's going to stop the cooking right
away to make sure that your yolk is
going to be cooked to your preference if
you leave them in the hot water or just
like take them out of the hot water and
don't cool them down then you'll get
that like really weird chalky like
grayish green yolk which we don't want
and just as a visual here are eggs
cooked at all these different times you
can see how much softer the yolk is at
four minutes whereas 16 is completely
cooked through
you just cut them in halves or quarters
throw them right on top of the salad
they add like a nice amount of color and
freshness i think they're also a really
good snack as well but there's a million
different recipes you can use for
hard-boiled eggs
all right so for poaching eggs which i
honestly don't think is too scary you
want to use a big pot of water there's
just like more room for the egg to kind
of move around and you want to make sure
that your pot of water is
i know this sounds crazy but like at a
hard simmer like you don't want it so
boiling that the water is really
disruptive and it's gonna shake the egg
a ton but if it's not moving at all then
the egg will just completely sink to the
bottom and there won't be any movement
rolling that egg white over the egg yolk
similar to scrambled eggs you're always
going to want to make sure that you're
cracking your eggs into a bowl first
and then we're going to do a whirlpool
trick so you're going to stick your
spoon in swirl the water and then that's
center whirlpool is where we're going to
drop our egg into as it's slowing down
is when you want to add your egg if it's
still going too heavy if the whirlpool's
too fast then the egg's just going to be
like whoa
you want to let the egg go and do its
thing in there until you kind of can't
see any of that translucent egg white
anymore with a poached egg you want the
egg yolk to still be quite runny but
again no one wants like a runny egg
white
and that is a poached egg
so we're going to blot it get all the
extra water off there
and then you're ready to eat so that's
the traditional method but if you were
doing a whole bunch we've got a trick
for you
so instead of a big deep pot we're just
going to use a saute pan that has
flat sides like three or four inches
deep that you can put some of these heat
safe glass bowls and have them
completely covered in water and for this
one i can do like three maybe even four
at a time depending on how big your
bowls are and how big your pot is and
then same deal you want to crack your
eggs into a separate dish but what i'm
going to do is actually go from one dish
to another and what that bowl is gonna
do is it's gonna keep the egg contained
in that space this is cool because you
can get a nice rounded shape every time
but it's gonna look a little bit
different than your classic poached egg
if you're just doing this for your
friends and family at home i don't think
anyone will mind it'll still taste the
same it's easier for you to do a whole
bunch of them and then it's a little
less intimidating way to approach
poached eggs
really good nice soft delicate way to
have an egg and it's also kind of an
impressive way to serve something that's
pretty cheap
i love poached eggs
yeah are produced your favorite wait do
we know i think my problem is i don't
have a favorite i like them all
if i had children they'd be eggs can't
really choose one right
depends on the day
[Music]